au Canadien qui compte leurs sous et
craignent une récession l'énoncé
économique offre un peu de répit et un
avertissement
[Applaudissements]
la hausse vertigineuse du coup de la vie
semble guider le gouvernement le terme
inflation apparaît dans le document à
115 reprises pour les Canadiens pour qui
c'est difficile à laquelle ou lorsqu'ils
font le plein l'inflation est en cours
trop élevé pour aider les plus
vulnérables
Ottawa prolonge l'allocation canadienne
aux travailleurs et enverra des chèques
plus souvent au lieu de le faire
seulement une seule fois par année trois
chèques de 714 dollars pour les
travailleurs célibataires trois chèques
de 1200 dollars pour les familles pour
les jeunes c'est la fin des taux
d'intérêt sur les prêts étudiants ce qui
leur fera économiser en moyenne 410
dollars par année nous comprenons que
qu'il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes
économiques dans le monde et que la
réalité est qu'aujourd'hui l'économie
canadienne est en train de ralentir pour
faire face à une possible récession la
ministre dégage un milliard de dollars
pour préparer une réforme de l'assurance
emploi et prévoit de nouvelles mesures
pour fouetter la croissance économique
un nouveau fond de croissance du Canada
un crédit d'impôt de 30% pour les
technologies vertes et 250 millions sur
50 pour former les travailleurs du
secteur pétrolier à une emploi plus vert
en plus de ces carottes la ministre
brandit aussi un bâton une nouvelle taxe
de 2% sur le rachat d'action par les
sociétés afin de les forcer à réinvestir
leur profit dans leur travailleur et
leur entreprise par rapport à d'autres
pays c'est comme les Etats-Unis le
Canada vraiment c'est un des pays les
plus faibles au niveau des
investissements privés le gouvernement
Trudeau met également de côté jusqu'à un
milliard de dollars pour la
reconstruction des zones dévastées par
l'ouragan Fiona dans un énoncé marqué
par l'incertitude économique le
gouvernement Trudeau a caché une
surprise de taille pour la première fois
depuis son élection il ose prédire un
retour à l'équilibre un premier encore
plus budgétaire d'ici 6 ans si tout va
bien malgré tout l'opposition reste sur
sa fin c'est du réchauffé
goûte meilleur mais il y a rien de il y
a rien de nouveau dans l'énoncé le
gouvernement à qui est promis d'être là
pour les gens à tourner les dos aux gens
pour le coup de chauffage le coup
d'épicerie contre qui continue
d'augmente cette stratégie même
inflationniste
augmente les taxes sur le chauffage
l'essence et les épiceries et nous
allons voter contre cette stratégie
inflationniste ce livre ainsi un
exercice d'équilibre contrôler
l'inflation tout en stimulant l’économie
entre l'aide au plus vulnérable et la
prudence fiscale le gouvernement marche
ainsi sur un fil de fer économique mais
aussi politique ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada Ottawa